في ليبيا تضرب الخلافات جميع الاطراف
السياسيه في مقتل
فعلى انقاذ اي اتفاق جديد يولد خلاف اخر
وسط تدخلات خارجيه هذه المره ترمي تركيا
بثقلها في خلافات الغرب الليبي وساطه
تركيه بين رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه ولايته
هو رئيس المجلس الاعلى بين عبد الحميد
البيبا وخالد المشري مصالحه تمت برعايه
خالصه من رئيس المخابرات التركيه الذي عقد
اجتماعيا المنفصلين احدهما برئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه والاخر برئيس المجلس لاخت
تمام بلقاء صلح بعد الخلافات الاخيره
للانتخابات
سي يصرف المليارات ويقاتل عبد الحميد باي
بني منعها رئيس مجلس الدوله حدث بينه وبين
رئيس النواب تقارب اخر لكنه فشل بعد
تصريحات تعقيل صالح بان الاتفاق مع المشري
لا يتعدى ان يكون لفظيا تصريح قابله اخر
قطع ورقه الانعاش الاخيره بين شخصين لم
يتفقا يوما اصلا في وقت تعود فيه المياه
الى مجاريها بين الدبابه والمشري الاخير
الذي ادعم فتح بشار بقوه ثم توسع الجفاء
ايضا بينهما لاحقا
تحركات تركيه في الغرب الليبي تقابلها
تحركات امريكيه اخرى شرقا وغربا حيث زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه الى ليبيا في محاوله للجمع بين
خليفه حفتر وقوتي العسكريه وعبد الحميد
البيبه وقوته سياسيه وذلك بعد اخر لا يغيب
عن التدخل التركي لتهدئه قيادات الغرب
وعقد هدنه بينهما في ظل الانتخابات
التركيه المرتقبه مع محاوله انقر المستمره
لايجاد موت قدم لها في الشرق الليبي
وتامين مصالحها وسعيها للامساك بخيوط
التطورات السياسيه الليبيه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه